the small blue sphere existed as one of
countless worlds within countless
universes developing their own lives and
civilizations all of which had been set
in motion by the one above all and
watched closely by the Living Tribunal
known as the multiverse beyond this
space existed what was known only as the
beyond verse housing the white Lords of
wild space while their origin is unknown
unlike the multiverse the beyond verse
did not allow for travel between the
past and the present instead the
inhabitants of the beyond verse move
forward from one point in time to the
next
towards a future that could not be
changed all the while developing
technologies and a level of power
hitherto unrivaled traveling back to our
universe and within the Andromeda galaxy
rested the planets scroll O's in the
Drakh system in its early days
approximately 100 million years ago
after their creation by the saurians
the scrolls existed as a reptilian race
not unlike the smaller reptiles of Earth
however after their exposure to the
Celestials during their journey of
exploration with scientific
experimentation much like humanity the
squirrel race was split into three sects
the deviants the Eternals and the
baseline scrolls with modified genes
allowing for future mutations while much
of the races history is lost to the
sands of time what we do know is that at
some point in their past unlike the
human Eternals who left earth to explore
the Stars the civil war between the
eternal and deviant Scrolls saw the
deviants victorious pushing the eternal
Scrolls to the brink of extinction with
the eternal Scrolls all the dead
the last of this group Avena and kleben
convinced the deviant queen sluggard to
spare his life and take his hand in
marriage offering up a truce in the
process leaving a scroll race into a
religion known as the book of worlds all
surviving factions of the scrolls were
united under this ideology and moved
forward and a manner akin to manifest
destiny believing it was their role to
rule over the universe
following this and for countless eons
the scrolls expanded their reach across
the andromeda galaxy but as their
exposure to and subsequent conquering of
other races while their number many
Scrolls became disillusioned with the
book of worlds slipping into the realm
of myth and legend the scroll Empire
went to war with itself each time
emerging more technologically advanced
and benign by weeding out those who
sought to bring disharmony to this end
and after having transformed into a
society of space explorers on a mission
of peace the scrolls travel to the
planet Hollow within the greater
Magellanic Cloud discovering the planet
house two equally intelligent races
known as the Kree and the Cotati for the
scrolls considering halle is a possible
expansion of their empire a group of
Korean Cotati were taken aboard a scroll
vessel and transported to the
oxygen-rich blue area of Earth's moon
provided with the years where the
supplies and instructed by the scroll
delegation to build something worthy of
their own race while the Cotati used
their plant like design to build a lush
jungle comprised of flora and fauna the
Kree built a massive city accessible
only to themselves and the scrolls
viewing the crow toddies benign work is
worthy of its initiation into the Empire
in a fit of jealousy the Kree killed a
Cotati and the scroll delegation looting
their ship and assimilating their
technology traveling back to their
homeworld the Kree waged war against the
remainder of the Cotati race pushing
them to the brink of extinction while
taking the planet of holo as their realm
following this and with knowledge of the
Kree assault in the scroll delegation
reaching the Kree homeworld the two
races fell into war with one another
which would stretch over hundreds of
millennia using their own forms of
science and technology to engineer
weapons of destruction the scrolls turn
their sights to opening dimensional
rifts for the purpose of accessing forms
of energy
guaranteed to annihilate their enemies
accessing the beyond verse through sheer
accident the scrolls secured a fraction
of the onder's power which confined
itself to the shape of a perfect cube
seizing it for himself and using its
power to control matter and energy the
scroll Emperor fancied himself a god
ruling without challenge unbeknownst to
the Emperor the cube develops sentience
copying the maniacal tendencies of the
Emperor and annihilating two-thirds of
the Andromeda galaxy
while the scrolls would rebuild their
empire and consider the Cosmic Cube to
be an artifact too dangerous to possess
after witnessing its power the Kree race
came to the realization that they would
need a guiding force without the
limitations of natural drive or possible
betrayal and so under the guidance of
the Kree Science Council the race formed
a sentient computer known as the supreme
intelligence containing the minds of
every career or the supreme intelligence
became as much a spiritual symbol as it
was a leader guiding the Kree with their
absolute loyalty the supreme
intelligence orchestrated the
development of the inhuman project as a
means to both subvert the squirrel race
as well as other races in an effort to
secure the kree's dominion over the
universe
however at some point in the races
history an unnamed member had attempted
to secure an artifact known as the
crystal of ultimate vision which allowed
its wielder to perceive and manipulate
the very fabric of the universe giving
in to his basic instincts the unknown
Kriya the final test which measure the
potential wielder spirit as a result the
evolution of the Cree race was frozen in
time keeping them in their current form
until the end of all things
on the other side of the cosmos the
Shiar were developing their own empire
originating with Shara and key 3
according to Shiar legend the two
possessed untold power but existed as
opposites through good and evil waging
war against one another forced to marry
through unknown means Shara and kii
three were presented with the m'kraan
crystal which had reformed to the birth
of this new universe representing the
union of Shara and key three the m'kraan
crystal came to be viewed as a sacred
artifact to this end the Shiar turned to
the crystal as a representation of their
races destiny to marry planets together
under the monarchy of the Shiar Empire
taking place over the course of yawns
and expanding across the corner of the
galaxy
unlike the scroll Empire which
functioned with the scrolls themselves
at the center of power the Shiar Empire
existed as an amalgamation of races with
each one swearing absolute allegiance to
the imperial crown there shortly after
this and in an effort to secure their
safety over their rule the Shiar
developed the Imperial Guard offering
all members of the Empire and
opportunity to participate each race was
allowed to send one member of their kind
who stood as the races strongest
individual as a result the Imperial
Guard was only comprised of a small
number of members but each one possessed
a unique power ranging from telepathy to
telekinesis to energy manipulation
while the Shiar Empire continued to grow
and expand within its own corner of the
universe the Eternals who had abandoned
earth had already taken up residence on
Saturn's moon Titan winding the clock
back prior to the Eternals abandoned the
earth the group found itself led by two
beings Kronos who sought peace and
Uranus who sought war with the
inevitable Civil War coming to fruition
Uranus and his ilk were exiled from
Earth eventually taking up residence on
Titan however because the Eternals were
at their core humans one of the elder
gods known as a dragon of the moon
reached out from its dimension and
looked to enhance his power by
corrupting the wills of men and citing
Uranus and his followers into a civil
war the entirety of the colony was
nearly destroyed save for sweets on an
eternal woman who remained alone on the
desolate moon following this and after
the remainder of Earth's eternal took to
the stars sweets on was greeted by those
who stayed behind and took up residence
on Titan as a means to continue
monitoring earth finding herself married
to a Lars around 20,000 years prior to
the current day a large and Suisse on
gave birth to two sons named eros and
panels developing a highly advanced
computer system named Isaac and
repopulating Titan while a large and
sweet saw and found themselves elevated
to the position of rulers over the moon
unbeknownst to the rest of the universe
a small corner of reality took a
different direction within the Cygnus
constellation and residing as a fourth
planet from its Sun then lost it as a
beacon of scientific and technological
superiority while its origin is shrouded
in mystery we can largely assume that in
the early days of its development as in
law experienced its own struggles as the
planets inhabitants came to understand
their place in the universe along the
way the Sun Lobby and belief in deities
began to fade following the rise of
throne the saint of science teaching the
people of zenn-la to concern themselves
with only what could be witnessed and
analyzed by their eyes the actions of
thron assured a scientific age of
enlightenment at the cost of creating a
rift between himself as well as his
fellow gods and as in la viens owing to
the idea that belief in mythical beings
defy the nature of science itself
using their knowledge of science and a
defensive capacity zenn-la saw the
issues of hunger disease and poverty
swept away to be replaced by a paradise
where each member lived without want
however this enlightenment came with a
high price as a race that had previously
experienced hatred and war the citizens
of zenn-la were not unlike humans and
that they thrived on freewill and
imagination while the early days of
their scientific discovery allow for
exploration of the Stars after charting
all things and learning all there was to
learn the act of retreating into
themselves left a void in their nature
with some turning to drugs and others
turning to suicide or escape into a
mental dreamscape while their society
did not crumble it slowly reduced itself
in number all the while becoming removed
from the goings-on of the universe
around the remaining secluded from all
existence in our stories I would
occasionally have somebody die or
introduce a serious subject I didn't
like to do it too much because basically
I feel comic books for anything I do
whether it's comic books or movies or
television or animation should be
entertaining and I never want to and
most of what I do is for younger people
I consider people in their 20s younger
in fact right now I consider people in
their 70s younger but at any rate it was
for younger people and I didn't feel
they should be burdened with too much
heavy stuff I felt they should read my
stories enjoy them and come away feeling
better but at the same time in trying to
inject some reality some realism into
the stories and also to surprise the
readers because it's important for a
reader never to know what's coming next
thought occasionally I should have
somebody die or get seriously ill
occasionally touch on some serious
subject now those are two separate
things the having somebody die was for
the sake of drama and holding the
readers interest